breaking news like this is really weird
and I'm not making a joke
Richard [ __ ] into his pants this morning
in like Richard and Sal share an office
and Richard just sitting there he goes
uh-oh I [ __ ] my pants it's horrible it's
like having a pet in there how bad it
would smell now horrible it smell [ __ ]
like fresh [ __ ] like fresh [ __ ]
like how do you do my talent man and you
do that lately he's been eating these
$2.00 breakfast round I saw oh by the
way I didn't mean to leave you out Steve
Steve nawicki
he shares an office he shares an office
with Sal and Richard and so you were
there for the [ __ ] usually I can
bear usually it's not that bad I had to
leave this morning it was so horrible it
really is gross
he almost shits his pants every day -
pretty much what every time he farts
this is what he files a well oh you know
when someone farts you're smelling their
[ __ ] I mean it's exploding in the air
yeah yeah it's particles of duty in the
air and lunch is even worse
you got to see I have pictures of these
lunches he brings in it looks like [ __ ]
in a bag it's something he makes in his
crock pot he goes i reheated this
chicken seven times how that is
disgusting what he showed this to Robert
she will bomb it just hold it up to the
glass so is he wearing underwear or did
he fall he's wearing underwear but I'm
guaranteeing you there's probably
holding up in the bathroom he ran out
he's been cleaning up ever come in here
Richard and you fully [ __ ] your pants
how do you do I didn't know no this was
a it was mostly contained in the cheeks
smell his hands felt guaranteed he's got
it under his nails no that's one thing I
do do is I wash my hands by the way
should mention there's no window in
their offices no how's his fingers smell
because you know he got [ __ ] on him
right these guys are acting all holier
than thou they [ __ ] a lot during the day
too if they shake they go to the
bathroom no but I mean they fart in our
office a lot to do dishes really
something wrong with you be [ __ ]
your pants at work
so we sit in your office no I can't read
while I'm paying you to work and you
can't go to your office cuz this [ __ ]
maniac I have no defense I'm sorry
Richard is like Tarzan like me [ __ ] me
beep pants
[Laughter]
[Music]